i've been reading a lot of old pessimist
philosophy recently
some old cosmic horror and apocalyptic
stuff as well
mostly from the 20th and 21st century
honestly it all seems pretty optimistic
now
with all servers down no new platforms
or apps
no new augmentations or vr's no new
shows
movies videos or any other forms of
content
i spend most of my time between an
abandoned still mostly untouched
antique bookstore in downtown and the
variety of spots i like to read at
around the city
i know all the best abandoned homes and
currently my favorite thing to do is
just bounce around between them
spending a week in one here another week
and one there
almost like a continuous vacation
through the rotting corpse of the city
there aren't nearly enough people left
to properly oversee and control all the
abandoned property
so even though it's sort of frowned upon
it's pretty much a free-for-all without
problem
at least so long as you stay clear of
certain areas
[Music]
today i was reading a book called the
trouble with being born
by a writer named emil charon according
to the back of the book
he lived sometime in the late 1900s it's
quite a good book in my opinion
i like the writing style what stood out
to me the most though
is how 200 years ago he wrote lines like
the following
man will not last ambushed by exhaustion
he will have to pay for his two original
career
for it would be inconceivable and
contra-naturam
that he drag on much longer and come to
a good end
and the further man proceeds the less he
is in a position to solve his problems
and when at the apex of his blindness he
will be convinced he is on the point of
success
then the unheard of will occur reading
people's thoughts and predictions about
how the world could have been
should have been or what they believed
it would inevitably be
is not only really fascinating but also
weirdly comforting
knowing that i know now what some of the
greatest minds in history
could only fear or speculate about makes
me feel almost like i am above them
it's my favorite literature to read both
those who wrote about high hopes for the
future
and those who had grim morbid views of
it
of course only tehran and other
pessimists and nihilists who shared
similar views
writing about catastrophic and
apocalyptic themes
at least got the premise of the plot
right ironically though
as i've been reading more and more
pessimistic fatalistic and nihilistic
philosophers
i've begun to consider the possibility
that in hindsight
if these sorts of ideas were taken more
seriously by a greater portion of the
general public
that all of humanity is afflicted
incompetent and absurd
and that there is no grand point nothing
to be won
nothing to be known or reconciled at the
end of everything in an
alternative universe it seems at least
possible to me
that these thinkers would have actually
been wrong about the final major plot
point
of humanity's collapse
based on how things transpired
theoretically it isn't that humanity's
fate was necessarily inevitable demise
but that since humanity could never
sufficiently realize this was the track
of fate it was on
it could not stop it humanity could not
see that it was on a train headed
towards a wall
so it just kept shoveling more and more
coal into the engine
of course part of its fate was that it
could not realize this
but in an alternative universe if it had
obviously things may have been different
in truth i don't believe we or at least
i can even conceive of a life where the
train stops moving
especially by our own accord even now
with mostly all bets off
with the world in shambles and the vast
majority of the species gone
i still want to try i still want to
progress forward and start anew
most of us do what could it even mean to
stop trying
to give up to lay down the torch of
progressive forward
movement stagnation and resignation go
against the very thing that we are
the very thing we were made by and will
continue to make and destroy from
we were pre-written to progress and
synchronize with the forward motion of
this exploding
destructive universe and so progress
is what we did and progress is what we
will inevitably continue to do
for as long as we are
[Music]
nothing makes it clearer than this
though that humanity does not own itself
what self-owning self-knowing species
would progress towards its own
disintegration
we are played like puppets by some
unknown force of existence
that scripts and runs the show religions
called it god
the philosopher arthur schopenhauer
called it the will to live
friedrich nietzsche referred to it as
the will to power in psychology
one could argue it was referred to as
the unconscious or subconscious
philosophers and scientists of all
different ages have described and called
it all sorts of different things
what it is how it is and why it is is
likely unknowable to humankind
however what it does is potentially
knowable
in the same way that we can't know how
or why a snake fundamentally exists
but we can know that it slithers around
and swallows its prey whole
so too can we know what the underlying
will or force of existence does
in relation to the apparent material
world
in my assessment being appears to
persist through a process of what i
would call
positive annihilation a continuous
increasingly complex cycle of
self-creation
for self-destruction the will to
annihilate
everything that has does and will exist
seems to operate through this process
each individual living thing is born to
die
each species is made to eventually
surpass or destroy
itself or be extinguished by some
external force of the universe
the universe itself as a whole was
seemingly created to end itself
arriving out of nothingness moving only
forward through time
decaying through entropy and finally
arriving at its final destination of
some sort of heat death
returning back to nothingness once again
it's easy to forget that what happened
at the beginning of everything
the big bang is still underway right now
the universe is still
at this very moment expanding and
decaying in a continuous explosion
towards total self-annihilation
and we are made out of this we are this
explosion
particles and debris made from it
manifested embers
unavoidably contained within the process
of burning existence
into its final ethereal ash
in the context of human experience the
manifestation of this will to annihilate
can be summarized as follows desire to
act or improve
action or creative efforts to improve
necessarily destroying or negating some
previous state in the process
unforeseen negative consequence of said
actions
and or a new state of dissatisfaction
and boredom
and then repeat over and over
humanity calls this progress which it is
but progress inescapably attached to
time and being
only moves according to the nature of
both
time moving forwards and being towards
entropy
or self-annihilation in broad sense
this can be observed in both the
individual and collective
the history of both one's own life as
well as the history of humankind
is a continuous process of self-creation
into self-destruction
madness mayhem erotic vandalism
devastation of innumerable souls
while we scream and perish history licks
a finger
and turns the page wrote thomas legatti
[Music]
there is nothing inherently wrong with
destruction annihilation or nothingness
and as an extension there is nothing
inherently bad about this process of
progress
even if it is towards self-annihilation
just like how life would arguably mean
nothing without death measured against
it
so too would creation mean nothing
without destruction and annihilation to
oppose it
it is the positive negative contrast at
the core of all being
that defines and creates all being
without it
there would only be nothing the problem
however
arises in our experience of the self
within this process
in truth i can say annihilation death
and nothingness
are not inherently bad in and of
themselves but to each existing
conscious human being
including myself generally they are
or are at least undesirable man did not
and still does not want to end
individually or collectively which is to
say there is an inherent conflict that
arises in the experience of self
if the will of existence operates
through a sort of process of
self-creation
for self-destruction and our
consciousness is a product of
and bound to this process and said
consciousness grants us a qualitative
personal experience of the process
but the qualitative experience of
disintegration and self-annihilation
is negative then the default experience
of self
is created with an inherent negative
relationship with its being
there's a squirrel scurrying around the
roof of a rotted out shed in the
backyard
of the forsaken home i'm riding in right
now there's a bird perched in a tree
just next to it
and there's a bug on the glass of the
window that i'm looking out through
every day these and all other non-human
animals
go about living with no conscious
concern over their ontology
they have no concern with the old or new
world order or lack thereof
they have no concern for improving or
progressing or taking over the world
from here
they have no interest in saving
themselves or the planet
and they generally don't cause any
problems that would require it
but we did all other non-human animals
live not without conflict but without
exasperating conflict
a human cannot help but admire and envy
this about them
it is arguably why we adore them so much
even those that would maul us at the
instant of getting too close
and yet at the same time most of us
including i
if we are being honest with ourselves
don't wish to be any of them
if given the option i would not choose
to be a squirrel
nor a bird nor a bug nor any other
animal for it would be the relative
equivalent
of wanting to no longer be alive i wish
to be like them however
free from the conscious tick to
endlessly desire and prefer
something else but still i do not wish
to be them
of course this is a contradiction i
cannot be like them
if i am me who is not like them only
since i am conscious
can i prefer to be like that squirrel on
the roof but only because i prefer in
this way
can i never be like that squirrel and i
believe the contradiction illustrated
here
is a sample manifestation of the
conflict between the self
and the will of being i prefer or desire
that which my consciousness does not
permit me to ever experience or attain
the elimination of preference and desire
all striving comes from lack from a
dissatisfaction with one's condition
and is thus suffering as long as it is
not satisfied
but no satisfaction is lasting instead
it is only the beginning of a new
striving wrote arthur schopenhauer
i am caught in the paradox of wanting to
not want
desiring to not desire trying to not try
knowing to unknow
[Music]
for some reason despite all of this
despite the seemingly unavoidable
conflict of being
and the likely impossibility of
resolution i still want to try to
resolve it
i want to see it through while there is
something left to be seen
perhaps it is the context of a broken
down world with a fairly clean slate to
start and rebuild from
perhaps it is the inclination to form
something else in the wake of the prior
perhaps it is the will to annihilate
carrying itself out through me
whatever the case there are not many of
us left but for those who are
if we are to have any hope i believe
this new time
is in desperate need of a new kind of
philosophy a philosophy that harmonizes
with the premise
that we are and have always been
impossible victims to ourselves
not merely to each other but our own
self
i'm not sure if humanity will survive
long enough or well enough
to begin any new projects for itself but
if it does
if humanity is to hold on if it is to
make use of its second chance
of its continuation it must attempt to
first free itself of all its delusions
it must from the very foundation
understand the total implications of its
conflicting
contradictory and poorly serving
relationship with itself
its consciousness and the world a new
philosophy must hold and comfort us
outside the whirlpool of our
consciousness and not push us any
further under
it mustn't pose nor seek answers mustn't
provide resolutions
nor desire for improvement mustn't
declare doctrines for how to live
no rationales for why but rather aid and
comfort us all
in the potential and likely
impossibility of successfully achieving
any of the above a philosophy that finds
resolution
reconciliation and eternalness in the
absence
of needing any a philosophy that
somehow consoles us
thank you so much for watching for
anyone interested the audiobook version
of my debut book
notes from the end of everything is now
available you can find the links to it
in the description below
on all platforms it is voiced by myself
if you have or do purchase a copy of the
audiobook or any other version
thank you sincerely the support and
positive feedback on the book in general
have been overwhelming and it is deeply
appreciated
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general
and see you next video
[Music]
you